DEFINITELY GONNA COME TO
HEARING HERE ARE GOING TO
CALL THE ROLL FIRST MAP
SECRETARY EDUARDO GARCIA
PRESENT PRESIDENT GALLAGHER
HELLO CARILLO TROY VICE
PRESIDENT CHIU FRIEDMAN FEAR
FREMONT PRESIDENT GLORIA
AYE HERE GLORIA PRESIDENT
KALRA THERE
PRESIDENT THIS HERE PRESIDENT
YOU KNOW HERE UNLESS WISH
GARRETT IS CHAIR OF THIS
GALLAGHER HERE GALLAGHER
GREAT YOU HAVE A QUORUM THE
FOR SIDE WILL BE BILL TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR LECTURE DOES HAVE
A NEW PASSED OCCURRED CENTER
LIMITS NONE OF THE BILL THAT
CANADA SHOULD BE SECOND THANK
YOU HAVE TO SPELL LA ALRIGHT
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS COMPLAINTS JUST BECAME
ALRIGHT WILL NOT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER WORKS BY THE
SHIRT MATHIS BROKAW THE MOTION
IS SENATOR MY MONTHLY I HEARD
YOU KNOW WHAT LET ME LET ME --
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ALRIGHT
WELL EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE GALLAGHER I GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW CARILLO CHOI CHOI AYE
CHU FRIEDMAN WHEN I LORIA ISIS
GLORIA AYE HARPER KALRA KALRA
AYE LEVINE LEVINE I MATHIS I
LIKED MATHIS AYE IS A FEW I
FEEL I SALAS SALAS I WOULD I
YEAH BUT THE WHOLE ISSUE NCCU
ELEVEN TWO ZERO HOUR WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN JUST FOR A MINUTE
BROTHERS TO ADD ON OKAY WON'T
BE OPEN BECAUSE THAT IS SENATE
SO I NEXT ITEMS A.
B.
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN CAMINO THIS
DOESN'T DO PASS CONCURRENCE
AND AMENDMENTS SIMILAR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR FUTURE
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN CREATES AND THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS HOSTAGE
CLOSELY WELSH THREE JUDICATA
PARDON WATER RIGHTS MATTERS
PALM THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR ITS GOOD GOVERNMENT
BASICALLY THE WATER BOARD
RIGHT NOW IS THE ON HIS BEHALF
PROSECUTORS AND THAT REVIEWER
AT THE SAME TIME THAT JUDGE
-- THIS CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU COLLEGE AND SO
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION
SECOND ANYONE WISHING TO ASK
QUESTIONS OKAY MUCH THE SECOND
QUESTION I JUST WANT TO SETTLE
THIS BILL TAKES FLIGHT HE
HOOKED ME OF OSCAR WAS EVER
THANK YOU AGAIN TO TAKE THIS
IS -- ALONG WITH THE SPREAD
OF AIDS TO BE ONE THREE OF
US ALL LAST YEAR SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT AND AND IT DOES
HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL HOW COME
MORE NARROW AND REQUIRED THAT
IN ONE HOUSE NO WHICH IS
BIG ENOUGH POSITION TO MEN
ALRIGHT EMOTIONS SECOND
BROKEN THE MOTION S.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED
IN EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE GALLAGHER GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW CARILLO CHOI CHOI AYE
CHU CHU AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
HARPER KALRA TELLS KALRA AYE
NPI ABOUT THIS -- AYE MATHIS
AYE RUBIO I DON'T KNOW I
SALAS SALAS I WOULD WOULD I
THE BILL GOES TO THE ASSEMBLY
FOR A THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH WE WILL ADJOURN
YOU ARE BUT WHAT I MEAN